cosa ci fa un musicista un tè di sé
dovrebbe suonare infatti suonerò poco
come prima cosa tradirò quello che è il
titolo che ho dato a questo incontro
questo speech perché mi sembrava un po
troppo settoriale parlare solamente di
musica mi interessava visto che il
titolo di questo di questo incontro in
generale e tornare a crederci mi
interessava parlare di quello che ho
capito nella vita
alcuni valori che ho capito attraverso
la musica io faccio un lavoro fortunato
perché riesco a lavorare con con
l'emotività con una parte molto profonda
di me e quindi vorrei riuscire a
trasmettere una serie di cose che
possono essere importanti sia per il
lavoro creativo perché ha la fortuna di
farlo ma in generale anche per forse per
la vita stessa
la musica di solito viene vista come un
una disciplina molto emotiva irrazionale
ispirazionale 1 sta alla finestra a
guardare il tramonto con gli uccelli che
migrano quelle l'uno per cento ed è
rapidissimo una deve essere capace nel
tempo quello capito codificato questo
questo modo di lavorare quell'uno per
cento poi a quell'uno per cento
corrisponde un 99 per cento di
traspirazione cioè lavoro consapevolezza
ricerca di soluzioni
questa è una bella metafora anche per
per la vita in generale se uno un sogno
da inseguire una visione del mondo
e importante capire quali sono i passi
concreti che uno può fare per realizzare
quel sogno per avere quella visione
nella realtà ma soprattutto in un
momento in cui si è diciamo molto
concentrati sul sull'individualismo e
importante invece di guardare verso il
basso verso se stessi
guardare verso l'orizzonte che è più
interessante sicuramente la musica
diciamo a una serie di valori che
trasponibili nella vita quotidiana il
primo è la trasversalità e anche quasi
una banalità dire che la musica è un
linguaggio universale io l'ho
sperimentato sulla mia pelle proprio
lavorando con musicisti di nazioni
diverse di continenti diversi ho
lavorato con dei musicisti inglesi
islandesi americani algerini che
parlavano solo l'algerino e ho passato
due giornate meravigliose parlando con
loro alla pari
questo è un altro tipo di trasversalità
oltre che geografica e interessante la
trasversalità anche di ceto di
possibilità che hanno avuto nella vita
ha avuto la possibilità di studiare
quindi a un certo tipo di linguaggio ma
ci sono persone che magari non hanno
avuto questa fortuna ma quando ci si
mette a suonare insieme si fa musica
insieme queste differenze spariscono
completamente e si vale tutti allo
stesso modo si dialoga se sono sembrano
banalità ma quando uno le vive sulla
propria pelle capisce la potenza di
queste di queste cose
un altro aspetto oltre questa
trasversalità in generale che va anche
per generazionale cia persone anziane
persone giovani possono dialogare
tranquillamente e il fatto che la musica
è una specie di cavallo di [ __ ] emotivo
potentissimo se io devo descrivere un
sentimento non so la nostalgia dico per
dire dovrei scrivere una molte pagine
con un linguaggio anche abbastanza alto
quindi già ridurre la capacità di
comunicare questa cosa mentre invece
attraverso la musica senza nessun tipo
di raziocinio bypassa la parte razionale
se io faccio se io suono questa cosa
molto semplice
non funzionanti rai
[Musica]
già subito uno si mette in un in uno
stato d'animo che fa pensare a qualcosa
di passato che manca ma anche senza
razionalizzarlo questo è la nostalgia
per la musica e ci vogliono dieci
secondi per spiegarla
mentre invece si vorrebbe un trattato
molto specifica non arriverebbe così
profondamente questa cosa mi ha portato
anche pensare che un altro valore molto
importante è quello di mettersi in
discussione in qualsiasi progetto che
abbia fatto generale nella musica
ho visto che è importante non
fossilizzarsi su un diciamo su un
modello acquisito in campo musicale ma
anche nella vita
tutti abbiamo aderito un modello è più
semplice e rassicurante chi è stato
fricchettone chi è stato dark che i
paninari questo tradisce un po la mia
età forse i paninari non tutti li
conosca comunque comunque se la sono
modelli a cui è neanche necessario penso
in adolescenza e gioventù aderire ad un
modello che ti dice un po cosa devi fare
per esistere per vivere
piano piano si dovrebbe liberare di
questo di questa gabbia che rassicura da
una parte ma ti imprigiona anche quindi
mettersi in discussione significa ogni
volta
cercare qualcosa di diverso stare sul
limite non sulla strada conosciuta e
quindi viene in soccorso sempre per
sintesi un mio caro amico eugenio
finardi che ha scritto una canzone anni
fa molto bella che si chiama non
diventare grande ma io l'accendo con la
mia voce
diventare grande ma
non serve a niente sai
bottino a crescere più che puoi
fermarti mai
avere ragione
ma statico una rete
ma è seguire la dinamica della storia di
mettersi sempre in discussione
vedere con quale sintesi in dieci
secondi ha spiegato una cosa che io già
malamente
ci ho messo più tempo e probabilmente
non sono arrivato così profondamente
come lui tra l'altro un inci piccolo
inciso si può parlare anche d'altro che
non di amore adolescenziale nelle
canzonette questo negli anni 70 era in
classifica
ecco questi valori attraverso questo
percorso
io sono riuscito a qualificare questi
valori che sono appunto trasversalità e
ne abbiamo parlato prima
e ho fatto parecchi progetti di questo
tipo in cui si incrociavano musicisti di
vari sì ma estrazione
questa è la notte della taranta con
steward copeland uno dei police con
il bassista degli area rais della
megretta un quartetto di percussionisti
che lavorano con philip glass e una
serie di musicisti brooks come potete
vedere molto popolari che sono le
tamburello e sono la musica tradizionale
salentina
ecco in questo in questa babele di
linguaggi si è riusciti a trovare un
nord a portare avanti un progetto in cui
tutti dialogavano e tutti valevano allo
stesso modo quindi trasversalità in
senso geografico
adesso vediamo queste visto la grande
orchestra rock che è un altro progetto
che ho fatto per il primo maggio a roma
in cui ho unito appunto sempre per la
trasversalità molti musicisti di
estrazione diversa musica classica jazz
tutti i più rappresentativi d'italia
c'era a boosta dei subsonica james
senese stefano di battista un
grandissimo jazzista il chitarrista di
vasco rossi e che tre stadi ligabue e
tutto questo è successo con la massima
serenità proprio perché c'è questa
democrazia insita nella musica un altro
valore
forse ancora più importante appunto di
cui ho parlato che è l'inclusività
l'inclusività come esatto contrario di
esclusività cioè di solito c'è
un'etimologia delle parole che ha dei
disvalori in sé esclusivo viene visto
come una cosa bella una cosa [ __ ] solo
per pochi in realtà è un disvalore
un po come privato la cui radice privare
invece uno degli obiettivi che ho
perseguito musicalmente ma poi che ho
capito che è una bella cosa anche in
generale nella vita è proprio quello di
comunicare le cose a più persone
possibile evitando i linguaggi criptici
o elitari che ti rassicurano ti fanno
sentire in particolare ma che in realtà
mostra una grandissima debolezza la cosa
da fare invece cercare di comunicare a
tutti delle cose importanti ed è una
bugia quella che il pubblico vuole
questo e al pubblico bisogna dare delle
cose semplici non è vero
io ne ho la riprova nella mia esperienza
personale cioè con i the producers
sempre per mettermi in difficoltà ho
messo insieme da produttore altri tre
produttori e uno scienziato per un
produttore che è abituato a entrare in
uno studio registrazione dire si fa così
se il capo assoluto è un
bell'allenamento al dialogo mettersi
insieme altri tre ego abbastanza
sviluppati come come il mio ti fa capire
quali sono i tuoi confini ti fa capire
quali sono le cose meno importanti a cui
poi rinunciare e tifa lasciare a livello
creativo solo l'idea la cosa più forte
più importante per metterla insieme alle
altre che saranno altresì importanti
quindi ti fa capire anche quali sono i
confini e dove finisce la tua libertà e
dove comincia quella degli altri
ma ritornando l'inclusività la parte
testuale
l'idea è stata quella di far diventare
la scienza la parte testuale per non
parlare d'amore ancora nella per
l'ennesima volta ma per parlare di
qualcosa di sostanziale di filosofico di
anche di quotidiano quindi il mio
obiettivo il nostro obiettivo è stato
quello proprio di far sì che le persone
vedessero un bel concerto
spero insomma siamo abbastanza grandi
per aver loro per per essere basasse
sicuri uno esce si emoziona ma poi ha
capito anche che cos'è il big bang che
cos'è la fotosintesi clorofilliana
e per finire diciamo che un riparo di
una cosa che non c'entra niente
apparentemente che il messaggio di a
residuo adesivo è un
radiotelescopio e in sudamerica da cui è
stato mandato 35 anni fa un messaggio
verso il confine dello spazio questo
messaggio in realtà e poi è proprio una
specie di grido siamo qui siamo qui per
cercare di tex a terrestri e da 35 anni
l'uomo ha mandato questo messaggio che è
un misto di linguaggio binario termini
scientifici ma anche parti molto naif
come il disegnino di un uomo il
disegnino del dna perché vi parodi
aggressivo perché secondo me il riuscire
a comunicare la cultura
io ho la fortuna di farlo attraverso la
musica ma in generale riuscire a
comunicare è riuscire a comunicare alle
persone a cui teniamo ai nostri figli è
un po il lascito che diamo alle
generazioni future è la cosa più
importante che lasciamo le generazioni
future secondo me che proprio questo
nuovo modo di collaborare
vuol dire che c'è un modo diverso di
organizzare gli esseri umani cioè che
questo sistema non è l'unico sistema
possibile grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]